welcome to this video this is a new
match against the computer computer
possible here on chess comm let's see
what I'm able to do yeah this is 5
minutes and 2 seconds increment just
like I'm headed this earlier match which
I played about a week ago I'm not quite
sure okay the usual game against the
computers to play as some dry as
possible not sacrificing anything trying
to keep it simple and I definitely try
to do that
that's a catalan which is not a bad
opening against the computer normally it
very often leads to a position that is
slightly better for white and not not
very risky ok so what is the computer
doing here Quincy ate it maybe we'll
play Bishop c5 trying to play against
the f2 but this discovery on f2 hmm
yeah III there is Knight d5 which is
yeah all I've gotten Bishop before the
Oh 96 hmm
yeah still I'm not sure if it is a good
idea hmm
yeah before is good play a 5
yeah maybe still protect this 95 Bishop
t4 shouldn't be that bad
okay that's something else okay well I
cannot take off this lip but still 95
maybe mmm okay yes it's cleared we'll
probably get the pond back anyway but
I'm not sure if it is so great maybe
okay Queen takes Bishop takes Queen g7
this always g7 hanging but after Bishop
takes it okay oh I don't like that so
much Bishop before though it can be
tricky if I take now to probably show
this this check here on B form that's a
bit awkward
hmm yeah Bishop g2 dresses check III is
a very slow move maybe I still need to
do it you really don't want to give one
to have this check here okay 95 this
Bishop deform unfortunately if I cancel
maybe Bishop b5
Luke Siwon he will just take on a three
ice cut the championships or it has got
the two bishops always have some
problems with the fact that this is a
computer not some sort of biological
entity okay Bishop a form it's not very
not very comfortable playing against the
two bishops iam not at all yeah Luke see
to be sure and drew a three Roxie three
and Roxie too
yeah an additional problem is my week
back rank of course yeah this is totally
lost the only vague hope is some sort of
miracle escape to learn to opposite
colored bishops endgame which really
it's very really unlikely to happen
sometimes you can try to seduce the
computer into that giving up a second
pawn maybe there is something like that
I that I can actually get in
yeah objectively it's just lost him but
okay trying to try to fight 92 somewhat
to know yeah I am dude this this night
is completely dominated by the bishops
yeah maybe I can maybe resign and just
save a bit of time but okay I will still
continue a bit you never know maybe the
computer is doing something something
really weird that can bring the king
over to the to the quaint side that's a
bit bit of it awkward
yeah
I'm still hoping for for this opposite
colored bishops endgame but it's not not
going to happen
yeah okay come on this I can and I can
resign with the clear conscience
okay so we'll rematch
yeah this b5 if it it irritated me a lot
in my opening okay let's see trying to
get a purely strategical position yeah
this is all very normal and I can I
could exchange a bit now with maybe
Knight a5 but it's not really it's not
really good not really good I mean no I
mean Queen a form that's not it's not
terribly dangerous move maybe okay but
then I okay by play now not g7 the
computer might take on c5 and put some
some real pressure on on me yeah Knight
a5 does not b5 which is really really a
problem
don't know me
rookie one gifted so it's not that I
didn't see it but I really didn't see
how to avoid it
hmm
Knight b5 and I probably but you don't
really and it's also 94 that's even even
worse Wow whoo not exactly great
the computer is not exactly bad and this
type of type of direct situations where
you have this pressure since this isn't
this strength quite viable I don't think
it is that's not so bad for black 97 I
can cancel yeah I can I can go here and
white will retreat I can't play 97 -
season maybe 97 26 knight on c6 is Sam
and quite nice good locating square
maybe I can get get rocks off yes it's
nice making my task a bit easier but
also exchange books no no okay if I call
Bishop f8 mmm
there should be three probably
yeah the rupiah is some is a bit a bit
of a problem our kids not doing so much
but still it's a bit awkward to always
think about this piece I have no easy
way to to get rid of it at least I don't
see it
right waveform Jeff really a computer
type move not clear what this piece is
doing besides defending defending here
you should eat five yeah look to this
seven probably but I still cannot
exchange young group ta-da look e7 I'm
losing before just of course a problem
there's no way to look b8 maybe Bishop
takes rook shake so this actually looks
quite okay yeah okay so now I can
actually go to d5 here or rook the rook
to AIDS to blunder stuff no don't do
that okay so I'll take now probably I'll
predict what the bishop even as weird as
it looks okay oh look yeah Roxy sadness
of wretches oh my to address that
okay if I go look T yes still he can
play Roxy seven okay strengthen this a
bit no it still evokes e7 or not
hmm nope c7 look she can take both
pieces but it's not not clear to me if
it is helping but I get age too well he
will trade now or it was right now this
is some an end game that I like against
the conga not sure how good it is but it
looks manageable hmm suppose maybe a
mistake knowing and knowing that's no
okay
nothing nothing serious happened that's
good
I was really worried to lose control
this isn't this better not for me maybe
it's maybe it's drawn but at least I'm
not losing yeah it is a draw they cannot
win not really but okay a draw is okay
I'd like to get on the on the scoreboard
here yeah well the computer will
probably not not do something stupid
okay why is this year draw now draw a
repetition okay so rematch at least I'm
on the scoreboard maybe there was more
possible but okay it's it's okay for the
moment yeah b5m this is the best answer
is e for but I don't know if it is a
good idea where the comp leads to
somewhat murky positions I prefer this
um this somewhat safer approach okay
yeah this is a type of Kings in Unitec
of course
not sure about about the setup here what
setup I should I should go for trying to
be very solid young yeah I like my
bishops but against computers if you try
to get to this very close positions can
sometimes be an idea to to aim for a
position where there with Knights that
seemed is going to try to see going to
flame before maybe before you okay this
is a dual mind getting a an eccentric
lowest for the moment okay so maybe it's
going for night a form okay not a for
Queen c2 okay so if five hmm yeah let's
let's close let's close it up before now
I cannot easily play because of the
caption and a4 is hanging okay I'd like
to prevent Bishop g5 and the night is
coming to d3 okay this is not good but
okay it's it's still very closed aha
okay so the computer is deliberately
closing the Queen side very weird trying
to get rid of this bishop okay that he
prevented or that it prevented
okay yeah that's a very nice position
now actually the queenside is closed but
this always night-night to the three of
course need to play oh yeah I'd love to
I'd love to exchange that night a 391
maybe I should go for that don't see an
issue if he exchanges this annoyed it
would help me tremendously yeah so this
was this was to be expected but okay
okay so
eh five okay I don't want to open it too
quickly some I have I have some time
here I don't need to to rush things
supportive for
okay yeah well g-force a move that in
general I would like to play opening up
them the kingside but it's not really
viable at the moment I wonder if I
should put a knight on on one before
actually baby it's may be slightly more
active compared to e1 but okay I have
all the time in the world I really I
really do it's no use to to rush things
yeah well g4 is not easy to play because
computers always attacking the h4 pawn
get the rooks on G and H okay the bishop
on h3 yeah I don't know should I play g4
here or not they're not easy
the timing I'm going for it opening up a
bit at least I don't see a drawback at
the moment okay
it will go to a computer may might try
to go to his 7 oh I would then I've got
night FIF and it's not so easy to do
okay I'm h5 here Scott Bishop g5 okay
hmm not not so easy to to make any
headway h5s maybe Bishop g5 I don't know
I don't see him don't see a big
alternative here okay now it wants to
exchange notes let's do that
okay the Queen has no square to end
that's good news
g7 and can I I cannot sacrifice em but I
can probably prepare that okay
now maybe here and try to to shuffle
like that
sure oh well that's a bit a bit awkward
yeah look g4 computer will take they'll
take on at five and after then it's very
well thats very difficult to do anything
okay yeah no I'm even giving and even
losing this bloody porn okay I can't
play this and B should reform well this
is the only thing that he still has left
as it has left is B form other than that
it's pretty much a fortress
yeah but before normally it's just
suicidal black computer might try to SEC
the exchange on h5 but it's not really
really great there are may be situations
where I can play f6 Bishop e6 something
like that really this is more of an idea
against the human player against the
computer I'm somewhat skeptical I wonder
if I can maybe do something against the
g5 upon gonna take the pawn but it's not
really doing much
yeah it's not exactly
exciting I know but that's life against
the computer this really okay okay it
can try to it can try to sacrifice on f5
that's true that's really true
we have offered to draw I was not sure
if I'm if we got 50 moves I wonder if
the computer really would play before
yeah it does it does crap shoot maybe
maybe I had some better way to set up my
position it's it's it's a pretty
uncomfortable now I must take and now I
cannot after this I cannot play route
III unfortunately what the heck that's
very very bad yeah it wasn't I mean half
I need to play this fortress in a way
that it is not that it's not possible to
to play the before pond and in this
position it really was possible my queen
a child is checkmate okay yeah this was
really bad I mean this was just just a
draw of course and just need you to find
some some other setup that is not it
makes it more difficult to play before
right okay I was always on this 20
something seconds
okay computers playing something pretty
much non theoretical something like a
very weird type of London system tonight
on g3 yeah okay it's at least a very
solid setup okay so you like to play C 5
C 5 that's possible yeah probably it is
I can also cancel first my castle first
it's a it's very good safe let's see hmm
okay well C 5 C 4 would be nice maybe I
can even prepare it a bit ok no no go C
5 hmm interesting
hmm what is this doing actually a 6 mm
just gives me the bishop so what's the
point
no should be 5 was just not doing much
at all okay mmm
if I mix the Queen he might play c4 like
win ce6 c4 you know play c4 takes not
that's actually quite good
Knight takes I have the idea to play
Knight f4 exactly so he needed to
address that yeah I don't care anymore
ever say he
so if instead of it it's just tricky to
do okay I'm so b3m computer intends to
play b3
and also a five might also play a 597
there's a five not it's not too
comfortable then be three okay it's not
the end of the world but it's also as
mentioned not particularly great the
Abbott okay this piece needs to move
anyway okay it did not play a five which
looked like totally normal
before seems too bad the move the
computer wants to play well this does
not seem to be like a huge problem but
at least at first I mean very often it's
it looks the computer moves look look
weird but they are technically justified
okay if I now trade roofs I don't think
I should do that
Abby should be fired annoying now that's
that's yeah this was a bad bad exchange
okay yeah I know I've got this this some
wreckage pawn structure d5 is really
weak well I have this counter play with
94 maybe maybe this is actually enough
to to make this a playable position
maybe it is the ship
night-night a four-headed that gives
away d5 Bishop f4 that would be never be
even nicer Knight to f5 mm it's not very
comfortable of course I can take that
and maybe go all the way to the six so
not to attract that but and an IG form
it's always this concrete stuff that you
can miss 94 is the problem king d6
Knight g4 okay okay I need to do it
anyway here okay computer does not play
that actually
yeah well Knight a force the counter
play that's clear but what does that
mean well f5 looks like total nonsense I
cannot do that maybe I can play Bishop
to d3 and then play a5 try to defend
that now the computer is doing that yeah
maybe the the H porn is just promoting
or something possible
I know that's the kingdom the king is
probably helping King III I mean this is
son maybe the the point okay I'd like to
have king of six and our D Phi was
hanging
yeah I have no no good square to do too
I can just push this okay yeah it's
tough it's tough against the computer
but the rook trades were bad because of
this should be fine
this up played really too quickly it was
pretty pretty obvious quickly that I
deserve a trickier position after that
okay you know the computers playing em
touch that shot set up trying to I don't
want this geez relief lines maybe this
is better suited against against the
machine okay to play d5 probably a 535
wow this looks like a really weird move
because of g5 kneeling down c6 and e6
okay maybe maybe that's still play oh
yeah always mighty for of course
and if I've yeah maybe maybe this is
still okay on a move like before my
computer I can play Knight e4 okay
Bishop f3 maybe covering
I mean playing against this advances and
okay this is supposed to actually my
hope to provoke that maybe this was it's
not really helping me it's possible I
can takes my t4 okay I want to keep this
Bishop yeah I take with the Queen there
is this e 5 which is quite an annoyance
okay and this was my intention anyway
yes that's that that's clear I mean
Bishop a4 but I want to keep this piece
on d4 the knight on d4
no age-3 this was my idea opening
opening the position yeah if I have very
concrete play as usual Joe takes Queen
takes not sure what this is this
position
yeah it's the computer wants to take on
therefore which I cannot really tolerate
I be a Brian I need to take really g3
maybe g3
very tough to evaluate very tough I
cannot really tell and then see five I'm
not sure what this position is might be
five but that's a six units the problem
is a six
I cannot go here because of Queen no
that's not possible actually Queen on
the long diagonal but how does it get
down not so quickly
neither so not not greater the Queen can
go to e5
yeah that'sthat's just totally totally
awful
let's see three threatened ok g3 was was
just just a very bad idea
yeah this III I cannot do something
against III that's my problem him sorry
but it was it was already a really bad
position okay this was five games it's
really really tough against this bloody
thing mmm
what is the best way to go something
like the King's Indian would be nice you
know the problem is after G three if you
don't get this type of super close
apposition so easily maybe I can get it
get it like that it's changing here and
then play e5 after d5 I would get the
type of position that I've yeah that's
that's the right structure at least
mm-hmm a six
and you play a 60 queen p3
maybe it's that sinners playing before
yeah okay so it would be very nice if I
can get my dark-squared bishop exchange
that means of each [ __ ] I had this
position already against this computer
and now I remember I came glad ga diem
to maybe computer can play G form now
retreat the Queen helping here on the on
the Kings side okay I don't mind some
trades at least against the computer I
mean against the human player I would be
skeptical here to trade too much stuff
why it still has the better end game
here but I hope that the computer it's
not playing this so great okay so let's
see g5 if I go Bishop h6 could be double
play g5 not not a very nice
I wonder if I should play f6 and then
Bishop h6 my computer my play g5
nevertheless
f6 g5
the night on g8 is not well placed here
it would be nice to to get it to okay
the computer wants to play Nazi form
okay
94 to 85 maybe yeah I hope that are not
getting too passive him I wanted to go
to age 7 actually okay
now we're taking on g5
okay so computer must must God the spawn
at the moment the Knight to a5 IDM is
annoying yeah but with a pin it like
Queen to c7 it's not so easy now to I
can simply move them that's that's
that's it's foolish what I did there
can from it's not a pin hmm okay trading
is not a good idea
another squeeze yet killing I screwed
this up again unbelievable
this was completely okay really at least
against this this bloody piece of
plastic
No Queen c7 allowing Knight a5 with the
temple just completely complete idiocy
yeah I move the knight this Quincy 8 and
I lose the whole Queen side unbelievable
yeah
I have no move I need to do that yeah
and now it's it's just over that that's
really bad I mean I cannot analyze him
that just as completely completely
unnecessary this loss and entirely
unnecessary rename here I need to start
with Bishop midnight h7 this is the
first first bad thing and then aim it
aim it to g5 yeah like it's just okay I
don't I don't believe in it and at least
one bit okay let's um let's see okay
I'll slay will to deform the computer
the last time also went for me stuff
like here this is this kind of openings
very closed very close positions Kings
Indian star this is actually what I
would I'd like to see or the Ben Oni is
also plain computer place that's pretty
terrible but still
okay h4 I really yeah I I see yeah
that's not what came where do I put it
probably to everyone Wow
yeah g3 rg4 really okay let's go g3
this is some really nice no but well
experience shows that even a super great
position can be easily screwed up
against this computer type defense Wow
five is unbelievable
ok let's see how to do that actually if
I go before instantly yeah well it
cannot go to default can really cannot
so let's do that
if I go yeah yeah it's a computer not a
human so see five that are not but to
try to prepare everything like the the
the utmost and preparation
night night here night to be six but I
can cover it with 93 yards I will do
that might be 693 he all might be five
or threatened okay let's get this rook
also entered play and nice wood beam
well I must play c5 her that's that's
pretty clear maybe be 5v5 could also be
good at the right moment but to came
let's let's use all the pieces committee
to look see one trying to to set up
everything well this is funny the HOH
file is really not it's not happening
much okay so if I move Knight to f3 one
just to prepare c5 okay so now c5 this
may be playable but I'd rather still
prepared more 923 and then c5
I could put the bishop to be 321
you know comparing this to that most the
should be 321 trapping the night almost
at computer might play b5 but then I
have c5
yeah that's it's very nice of this
labored I'm still I'm still a bit
cautious here with good reason probably
I can also take a four and then advance
with like b5 yeah it's also quite nice
besides c5 of course should I decide I'm
not sure they all probably win but b5 is
also good at taking a four yeah that's
that's that's that's probably the best
just no take here and now night before
two three six yes there is no counter
play inside I don't I don't see any
counter play Bishop to b6 maybe but I
can take now here all night
Knight to c6
yeah it's that it's okay I mean it's
just a completely completely lost
position but you keep keep trying to you
always know mostly Lewis look out for
those kind of computer stuff defenses
that sometimes really really come out
okay okay take with you have the both
William but here probably
I'm still cautious I don't want to screw
this up
absolutely not not this position okay I
can just take these six right with c7
and stuff yeah this rook g3 with a check
the check I can take this has made okay
wow this was too bad the opening and I
always kept kept control of this it's
the problem is to get to get to the to
get to the kind of position you need
I mean after he played long castles I
mean this is totally totally crazy white
is winning after that strategically but
it's you know like I kept playing the
the most solid safe stuff everything
protected kind of chess so that there
wasn't really anything anything possible
this this was probably quite nice
getting this night to d3 yeah I think
it's around here you you have various
various possible it is even c5 is as
possible directly but this this is
pretty strong because I get I get to a4
and then it's also
why it is also yeah winning with the
kingside King side attack okay so I lost
this match Frey than a half to one and a
half but I close the video now stop it
with almost one hour play time I hope
you enjoyed it it's always very tricky
against this machine but at least I'm
got a winning thanks for watching